m
oui
il ya quelques semaines j'ai la chance
de rencontrer joseph pfeifer joseph
pfeifer c'est un ancien commandant en
chef des pompiers de new york est l'un
des premiers à être intervenus sur les
lieux de l'attentât du world trade
center le 11 septembre 2001 à new york
le 11 septembre 2001 il y a vingt ans
donc deux avions de ligne sont détournés
par des terroristes groupe al qaïda il
s'écrase sur le tours jumelles du world
trade center le plus grand symbole du
capitalisme américain dans cette vidéo
nous allons bon que revenir sur cette
journée qui a marqué non seulement les
états unis mais aussi le monde entier et
pour nous joseph pfeifer dévoile avec
émotion les coulisses de cette journée
qui a fait basculer sa vie à jamais
cette vidéo est réalisée dans le cadre
d'un partenariat avec la chaîne national
geographic
à l'occasion de la diffusion de la série
11 septembre un jour dans l'histoire
vous en dit plus à la fin de la vidéo
est d'ailleurs la plupart des images
d'archivés que vous verrez dans la vidéo
sont tirées de cette série
le matin du 11 septembre 2001 joseph
pfeifer et son équipe sont appelés pour
une fuite de gaz au croisement de deux
rues c'est donc une journée plutôt
ordinaire ensoleillé une fuite de gaz
sur une intervention de routine pour les
pompiers du new york fire department met
soudain à 8h46 les pompiers sont surpris
par un bruit assourdissant un bruit
inhabituel dans les rues de manhattan
ce jour-là un réalisateur français juno
dès qu'ils réalisent en fait un
documentaire sur les pompiers de new
york suit donc par le plus grand des
hasards le chef de bataillon joseph
pfeifer et son équipe jules naudet film
tout est tout d'un manche joseph pfeifer
apparaît à ce moment là très calme du
cru mes bras avec
le chef pfeiffer remonte alors dans son
véhicule pour se rendre sur place il
fait par radio son premier rapport
officiel sur l'attentât
elle est noble grosse
frayeur face
au monstre trois minutes plus tard
joseph pfeifer et sa brigade arrive au
pied de l'une des tours jumelles c'est
la tour nord ils vont alors y entrer par
l'entrée principale
la scène à laquelle ils sont confrontés
est alors inimaginable apocalytique
toutes les fenêtres du hall sont briser
les vitres et les portes d'ascenseur son
souffle et les plaques de marbre au mur
sont arrachés en fait le kérosène de
l'avion est tombé du haut par les cages
d'ascenseur et en arrivant en bas de la
tour se kérosène a créé une forme de
boule de feu qui a détruit le rôle et
qui a propulsé des personnes à travers
les fenêtres en tant que premier grade
est présent sur les lieux joseph pfeifer
prend alors la direction des opérations
dans le centre de commandement pas de
panique nous sent bien que l'attention
est présente les renforts new york fire
department arrive progressivement au fil
des minutes qui parmi ces renforts est
bien joseph pfeifer va croiser le regard
de son frère pompiers vient aussi plein
d'inquiétude
est né
[Musique]
cette croix
qu à
cet univers joseph ordonne alors aux
pompiers de se séparer en deux groupes
d'un côté ceux qui doivent tenter
d'éteindre le feu et de l'autre côté
ceux qui sont chargés d'évacuer le
bâtiment
de
type
les pompiers informe joseph pfeifer
qu'aucun des ascenseurs nous fonctionne
il comprend donc alors qu'ils vont
devoir utiliser les escaliers il donne
alors l'ordre aux pompiers de ne pas
monter au delà du soixante dixième étage
car on lui signale d'abord que le feu
est en cours au 78e étage et au dessus
des
attentes
des analystes
les escaliers sont assez étroit les
pompiers monte au fur et à mesure et
commencent à évacuer les personnes
présentes dans le bâtiment étonnamment
dans ses cages d'escaliers l'évacuation
se fait dans le calme et la discipline
pendant ce temps là joseph pfeifer est
toujours dans le hall et quelques
minutes avant 9 heures ils donnent un
nouvel ordre celui d'évacuer la deuxième
tour la tour sud par mesure de
précaution à ce moment là il ne s'est
pourtant pas quelle sera la suite des
événements
de nos
deux championnats ocz quelques minutes
plus tard à 9h03 une seconde explosion
assourdissante se fait entendre un
deuxième avion lieu aussi faisait
tourner vient de s'écraser sur la tour
sud
dec
oui ce soir
après s'être regroupés l'équipe de
commandement est alors divisée en deux
à 9h59 c'est un troisième bruit
assourdissant différent des deux
premiers surprend les pompiers dans
leurs interventions
la tour sud percutée 56 minutes plus tôt
ces fonds
[Musique]
et à cause des débris et de la poussière
provoqué par cet effondrement c'est le
lobby de l'autre tour la tour nord dans
lequel se trouve alors joseph pfeifer
qui devient complètement
faire ou alors une vingtaine de mètres
et tout le lobby pour se réfugier dans
un couloir à nous
connecter sur la radio elle achète
alors que le monde entier a assisté à
l'effondrement de la tour sud en direct
à la télévision les pompiers de la tour
nord dont toujours aucune idée de ce qui
vient de se produire c'est le black out
lequel nom de communication des pompiers
est complètement détruit
le
[Musique]
vtt
et canada tim
une fois à l'extérieur face au world
trade center joseph pfeifer découvre
alors une scène apocalyptique entre
poussières et débris
et croiser des regards complètement
ahuri et quelques minutes plus tard à
10h28 joseph pfeifer entend quelqu'un
crier que la tour nord est elle aussi en
train de s'effondrer
joseph pfeifer toujours accompagné
d'ailleurs par le réalisateur jumeaux
des cours en direction du fleuve hudson
mais avec son casque sont lourds
équipements il ne parvient à parcourir
que 50 mètres à côté la tour nord s'est
entièrement effondré en tout juste bons
à
être non mais
puis d'un coup le temps semble s'être
arrêté
[Musique]
suivant le souverain de brousse du rove
à
jules et joseph parviennent à se relever
il se dirige au milieu de la rue sans
rien voir les stocks
[Musique]
de
sang et les pompiers se dirige alors
vers les décombres des deux tours n'est
pas sot et boston like we wish to stay
tuned
for twitter
sur le millier de pompiers mobilisés
343 n'ont pas survécu ce jour là parmi
eux kevin le frère de joseph pfeifer
joseph apprendra plus tard que son frère
a passé ses derniers instants à aider
d'autres pompiers à évacuer la tour ce
qui a retardé sa propre sortie par
ailleurs le pompier qui s'était arrêté
pour secourir une femme qui ne pouvait
plus marcher est quant à lui parvenu à
sortir vivant tout en sauvant la vie de
cette femme one of
story mais on estime à environ 15000 le
deux survivants de ces attentats
nous
sommes
fatigués de cette attaque reste encore
aujourd'hui l'attentât le plus meurtrier
de l'histoire des états unis avec un
bilan de deux mille sept cent cinquante
morts dans les deux tours deux autres
avions de ligne ont également été
détourné ce jour là l'un a ciblé le
pentagone donc le ministère de la
défense américain l'autre celle 8 écrasé
avant d'atteindre sa cible qui semblait
être le capitole où se trouve le
parlement américain le bilan total de
cette journée est donc lourd avec près
de 3000 morts et plus de 6000 blessés
ces attentats ont donc provoqué une onde
de choc mondiale les images diffusées en
direct des avions heures tant le world
trade center puis l'effondrement total
de tours jumelles ont été vues ce jour
là par des centaines de millions de
téléspectateurs à travers le monde
bonjour à tous ce flash spécial pour
vous annoncer c'est très spectaculaire
explosion se serait un attentat depuis
bientôt trente six heures de terribles
images nous parviennent des états unis
au lendemain des plus graves attentats
terroristes de l'histoire les premières
images qui nous parvenaient hier
après-midi était impensable tout le
monde pensait regarder un film de
fiction mauvais fille malheureusement
c'était bel et bien la réalité
julie
navarro
linares
le soir même de la tacc depuis la maison
blanche le président des états unis de
l'époque georges da beaulieu bouche
déclarera d'ailleurs la guerre contre le
terrorisme
en novembre 2002 la commission nationale
sur les attaques terroristes contre les
états unis dit commission du 11
septembre est créé par le congrès
américain et son objectif il est clair
enquêter sur les causes et les
circonstances de l'attentât ce qui
aurait pu empêcher une telle attaque
mais aussi faire des recommandations
pour qu'un tel drame ne se reproduise
plus son rapport publié en 2004 pointe
alors les failles du renseignement
américain en amont mais aussi le manque
de communication entre les différents
services d'urgence la police les
pompiers ou encore les ambulanciers le
jour de l'attaqué
le
système
où tous
peuvent
investigateurs suite 11 septembre la vie
de joseph pfeifer a radicalement changé
chez les pompiers new york il a pris la
tête du service de lutte contre le
terrorisme et de préparation aux
situations d'urgence il a donc consacré
le reste de sa carrière à se préparer à
d'autres possibles attaques appliquons
les leçons tirées du 11 septembre
après les attentats du 13 novembre 2015
à paris joseph pfeifer s'est d'ailleurs
rendu en france la crise près de reading
dans
ce cas si tu
craques des pionniers au cours de cet
entretien en racontant ce qu'il a vécu
joseph pfeifer a répété plusieurs fois
le mot espoir de cet événement il
ressent surtout l'héroïsme dont ont fait
preuve les pompiers de
chirac
en 2018 après 37 ans de service joseph
pfeifer a acquitté les pompiers de new
york il est aujourd'hui un chercheur et
enseigne dans une école de l'université
d'harvard dit merci à national
geographic d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo je disais si le sujet vous
intéresse la chaîne diffuse à partir du
2 septembre à 21h la série 11 septembre
un jour dans l'histoire vous y
retrouverez le témoignage de joseph mais
également celui de nombreux autres
survivants aux histoires bouleversantes
en tout la série a nécessité trois ans
de travail et compile 951 1h10 images
d'archivés voilà donc pour cette
nouvelle vidéo ce nouvel échange
exclusif sur cette nouvelle chaîne
youtube hugo décrypte joseph pfeifer
vient de sortir un livre ordinary
creamers que je vous mets en description
si ça vous intéresse un grand merci à
joseph pfeifer pour son temps merci
aussi à national geographic d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo j'espère en tout
cas que cette rencontre vous aura plu si
c'est le cas sachez que vous pouvez
retrouver d'autres rencontres d'autres
vidéos de ce type là sur cette nouvelle
chaîne youtube en plus de la chaîne
youtube consacrée aux actu du jour sur
cette chaîne là vous allez donc des
reportages des entretiens des échanges
exclusif pensez donc à vous abonner je
ne sais pas encore le cas pour nous
soutenir et pour ne pas louper la vidéo
suivante je crois j'ai tout dit
connaissent entre vous pressent vos
proches et on se dit ah très vite